E aí
[Aplausos]
e os dados da violência doméstica levada
ao extremo em nossos dias são
aterradores com academia em São Paulo
houve aumento em
44,9 por cento dos casos de agressão
contra a mulher isso comparando 2020.com
2019 os casos de feminicídio aumentar em
46,2 por cento além de São Paulo foram
coletados dados apontando crescimento
elevado nos casos no Acre no Rio Grande
do Sul no Rio Grande do Norte no Mato
Grosso e no Pará esse dados foram
publicados pelo Fórum Brasileiro de
segurança pública
é a questão da agressão física da mulher
tem raízes Profundas
remonta a organização patriarcal da
sociedade que deram o homem a condição
de proprietário da mulher que tem a ver
com razões históricas físicas políticas
sociais e religiosas da submissão da
mulher e essa agressão ela não não tem
sido habitada por crenças equivocadas
das quais exemplo o lema em que em briga
de marido e mulher não se mete a colher
quem já não ouviu essa frase antes
Ah e quem já passou pela situação de
intervir
permitido a colher e depois a própria
mulher decide voltar e se submeter a
mesma situação
e o que você faz depois disso
perdendo novamente
é um evento mesmo traumático quando
acontece repetir das vezes diante de nós
se torna aparentemente normal é assim
que a violência passa a ser só
socialmente com sentida
o segundo pesquisa da de of state
fundation o abuso financeiro responde
por 98 por cento dos casos de violência
doméstica contra a mulher nos Estados
Unidos apesar de no Brasil não dispomos
de estatísticas que revelem dado
semelhanças Existem algumas iniciativas
que Na minha percepção demonstra um
reconhecimento de que a educação
financeira contribuindo assim para a
redução das taxas de feminicídio por
exemplo no Espírito Santo o projeto
mulher superando o medo uma iniciativa
do Tribunal de Justiça do Espírito Santo
passou oferecer atendimento psico-social
e cursos de educação financeira para a
vítima da violência doméstica a partir
de fevereiro de 2020 pouquinho antes de
decretada a família o objetivo é
ajudá-lo a aumentar suas rendas EA
conquistar a independência financeira
para que essas mulheres não dependam
mais e eu não gosto
e o governo federal através da
Secretaria de Justiça e cidadania
é isso em parceria com a Caixa Econômica
Federal também desenvolveu um projeto
semelhante com o mesmo propósito o
Tribunal de Justiça do Distrito Federal
e territórios não sou o curso de
educação financeira para vítimas de
violência doméstica
nós sabemos que as raízes da violência
contra as mulheres estão na
discriminação histórica sofrida pelas
mulheres e que seu papel na sociedade
era vista como secundário e como já dito
na organização patriarcal em que a
mulher era coisa e ficada com
propriedade do homem
e sabemos também que a complexidade do
tema exige muito mais que iniciativas
isoladas mesmo que bem sucedidos exige
um aumento gigante na consciência de
todos nós para gravidade desse flagelo O
que é a violência contra a mulher
e nenhuma mulher merece ser agredida
pelo simples fato de ser mulher
e a Lei Maria da Penha é um Marco no
reconhecimento dos direitos das mulheres
como direitos humanos no Brasil é a lei
11.340 de 2006 A Escalada da violência
reduziu em 10 por cento desde que a lei
entrou em vigor em 2006 segundo
levantamento do ipea em 2015 mas as
mulheres continuam sofrendo violência
moral e física pelos seus companheiros
muitas vezes o sal gozos são aqueles que
Prometeram amar e cuidar delas até que a
morte os separe são aqueles que elas
escolheram para ser os pais dos seus
filhos
a Segunda Lei Maria da Penha a violência
contra as mulheres passa a ser definida
como qualquer ação ou omissão baseada no
gênero que cause morte
lesão sofrimento físico sofrimento
sexual sofrimento psicológico e dano
moral ou patrimonial
e a violência patrimonial que vão chamar
a partir de agora de abuso financeiro é
entendida como qualquer conduta que
configure retenção
subtração destruição parcial ou total de
seus objetos e instrumentos de trabalho
documentos pessoais bens valores e
direitos ou recursos econômicos
incluindo
os destinados a satisfazer a necessidade
básica dessa mulher
e ainda segunda allstate com deixa 22
por cento das mulheres americanas não
entendem o abuso financeiro como um tipo
de violência doméstica
66 por cento dessas mulheres sequer
ouviu falar ouviu muito pouco sobre
alguns financeiro como forma de
violência doméstica mas está mudando de
2014 para cá consciência tem aumentado e
o número de mulheres que ignoram temos
está reduzindo a educação financeira é
uma ferramenta que pode ajudar milhares
e milhares de mulheres a garantirem a
sua independência
integridade física mas de novo é preciso
ampliar a consciência e agir
coletivamente
o que permitam contar uma história
já era final da década de 60 e o que me
vem à mente é uma cena em preto e branco
e que meu pai começa a agredir minha mãe
com o centro dentro de me agarrar as
pernas dele chorando gritar não faz isso
pai
Tá mas me via tirada sobre minha mãe que
estava no chão e nós duas temos
agredidas pelo centro do meu pai
a cena desaparece da minha mente não meu
pai não era um monstro ele repetia com
aquele Gesto o que aprendera com seus
pais e avós porque ele tinha sido
ensinado como modelo mental do homem e
portanto o que a ele era permitido fazer
com a mulher
me sinto confrontada com tantos casos de
violência contra a mulher nos dias de
hoje e esse confronto me conectar com
experiências passadas e vividas quando
eu ainda era uma criança e no despertou
para a realidade de que mais 50 anos se
passaram e fatos com aquele ainda fazem
parte da realidade de muitas crianças
hoje
se nenhuma mulher merece agredida pelo
simples fato de ser mulher nenhuma
criança deveria enfrentar uma
experiência e para ter que carregar em
sua mente inconsciente e vê-la Em algum
momento de sua vida adulta voltar e
produzir consequências
que não se pode prever
e eu não tenho consciência de como era a
relação de meus pais com dinheiro mas eu
sei que minha mãe não tinha autonomia
financeira porque eu me lembro de uma
frase que ela dizia de vez em quando se
tivesse condições de me sustentar e as
minhas filhas ir embora para minha terra
e
é possível identificar ou menos dois
grupos dois grandes grupos de mulheres
financeiramente vulneráveis no primeiro
grupo estão as mulheres que por escolha
ou por circunstâncias não exercem uma
atividade remunerada mas é pende
financeiramente seus companheiros e que
se submetem abuso financeiro no corpo na
mente nas armações por não se acreditar
em capazes de prover o próprio sustento
de seus filhos
as crianças essas por elas próprias
adquiridas por ensinamentos ancestrais
oi oi
curtidas pelos próprios companheiros
É nesse grupo pode estar mulheres de
quaisquer classes sociais no segundo
grupo mulheres que exercem atividade
remunerada ou que tem o renda passiva de
herança por exemplo
salários pro labore de viveiros mas que
abre mão do próprio poder financeiro e
favor seus companheiros por acreditarem
que como mulher não tem capacidade ou
habilidade de administrar o próprio
dinheiro
e agora imagine você diante de uma
vitrine olhando para um tênis e dizendo
vou comprar seu marido do lado diz não
você não precisa gastar esse dinheiro
porque eu tenho que você tem ainda está
bom
quem a considere que o dinheiro que não
precisa ser gasto é seu
e imagine agora uma outra situação você
chega em casa e encontra notificações de
que as prestações da sua casa não foram
pagas e que ela pode ir a leilão
o dinheiro que você contribue para o
orçamento familiar o quê que foi feito
dele
a minha mãe não se encaixava totalmente
nenhum desses gosto mas tinha um pouco
de cada ela trabalhava na empresa com
meu pai precisa dele mas não têm
remuneração e também não tinha liberdade
com dinheiro precisava da permissão dele
para fazer um gasto fosse para ela fosse
para casa ou para nós suas filhas muitas
vezes para atender uma necessidade ou
desejo o mesmo se de idade algum
agressão ela tirava dinheiro do caixa
escondido a falta de controles ajudava a
camuflar essas retiradas extras eu vivi
no ambiente onde a relação com dinheiro
era confusa como tabus crenças
limitantes coisas escondidas Pois afinal
não era coisa de mulher
e essa relação caótica com dinheiro
inconscientemente influenciou muito
minha vida e os efeitos eu comecei a
perceber quando iniciei minha vida
profissional
desde meu primeiro salário eu vive um
caos financeiro
não por imposição de algum parceiro que
durou muito tempo até até que eu tomar
consciência e começasse a mudar meu
sistema de crenças meus pensamentos e
minhas atitudes
e a educação financeira não salva apenas
a vida de uma mulher
que é agredida pelo companheiro pode
salvar gerações
é uma outra cena também preto e branco
me vem à mente que a minha mãe
carregando uma mala uma pequena mala eu
e minhas três irmãs não segurando uma
nas mãos na outra E literalmente
agarrada a saia dela a caminho da
rodoviária eu senti a tristeza daquele
momento de forma muito concreta de
repente uma mulher vem em nossa direção
gritando não faça isso como você vai
conseguir sustentar essas meninas como
você vai conseguir dar a elas a mesma
condição de vida que tem aqui você vai
passar fome
Esquece essa bobagem e volte para casa
ela voltou ela acreditou em cada palavra
ela acreditou que não era capaz
mas ela foi em cansada em sua
simplicidade
em curtir na nossa mente que temos que
estudar ter uma formatura e trabalhar
para ter independência se
casar depois
lembro de uma frase que ela repetiu com
muita frequência Tude
trabalho para não ser dependente de
homem nenhum ela conseguiu essa geração
foi salva
quantas mulheres em nossos dias
continuam acreditando e suas limitações
e se acomodando por medo por insegurança
por crença de merecimento ou de
incapacidade
a educação financeira é absolutamente
necessária para essas mulheres porém não
é suficiente uma abordagem eficaz deve
incluir apoio psicológico e educação
para o trabalho por isso que os
programas exemplo do que acontece no
Espírito Santo Brasília devem contemplar
apoio psicológico capacitação básica em
finanças pessoais e oficinas laborais e
e a entrega de resultados efetivos que
reduzam os índices de abuso
financeiro deve ser feita com a
integração das forças que representa
essa comunidade com mais longas da
sociedade civil nas diversas esferas do
poder público
as empresas as entidades religiosas nas
universidades enfim tanto pontos for
possível sensibilizar para contribuir
com a mudança dos números da violência
contra a mulher nesse país
como mulher empreendedor e dedicado ao
empreendedorismo feminino me sinto na
obrigação de me apresentar para essa
luta confesso que são realizados somente
isso que eu queria era mais fácil para
mim continuar na posição de enviar não
que essa posição não seja muito
necessária precisamos de financiadores
da obra
é mas só contribuir com algum dinheiro
ou mobilizando rede de contato para
ajudar determinada iniciativa de uma
honra e de uma igreja por exemplo mas
fechando as portas da minha emoção para
não sentir a dor de algumas delas já não
é mais suficiente
sei que para ser parte do batalhão que
vai enfrentar tamanho desafio eu vou
precisar de mais do que vontade de
fazê-lo terei que me preparar e como bom
soldado você tem nada na mente e nas
emoções para lidar com a dor das outras
e efetivamente ajudar
O que é preciso arrastar seguidores para
essa causa tanto para corrigir quando
para prevenir no campo da prevenção à
educação financeira Precisa ser
considerada nas escolas desde educação
infantil E aí eu Trago essa provocação
para que escolas públicas e privadas
reflitam sobre a adoção desse conteúdo
nos currículos escolares
e no campo da correção é preciso
viabilizar econômica e operacionalmente
projetos voltados para educação
financeira de Mulheres vítimas de abuso
financeiro e aí é inevitável convocar
para o centro da são as prefeituras as
Universidades as empresas privadas E aí
considerando que há poder me ajudou e
estimular práticas de apoio social
empresas que entendem que tratar o meio
ambiente as pessoas EA governança PSD
produzem diferenciais inclusive
competitiva de mercado precisamos atrair
a sombras e é para ir pessoas físicas
sensíveis à causa homens e mulheres
podem sisto que o que vai contribuir
para acelerar o processo de redução dos
índices de violência contra a mulher a
nossa consciência e posicionamento Firme
em dizer não à violência
e quanto a você vai continuar
acreditando que em briga de marido e
mulher não se mete a colher
você já decidiu não se calar diante de
uma mulher sendo espancada na casa ao
lado da sua
e não importa o tamanho da sua ação
mesmo que pareça muito pequena para você
sai daqui um movimento o seu pode salvar
uma vida é
[Aplausos]